Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking it.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue
low.
My kittens.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I'm testing a new mic,
so if it sucks balls,
please let me know on Twitter Hashtag
suck balls. Otherwise if you'd like it,
Hashtag like balls. I'm kidding. Don't do
that. Don't do either. Actually just uh,
communicate with me like human on the
interwebs instead of using hashtags.
Thank you very much.
The Tim Ferriss show is typically
involved with deconstructing world class
performers, trying to identify
the routines, the tips, the books,
the influences and so on that helped
you to replicate the successes of people
who are the very best at what they do.
Whether they are hedge fund managers,
actors and politicians like Governor
Schwarzenegger for instance, uh,
musicians like Mike
Shinoda, blah, blah, blah.
Everyone in between chess prodigies,
we've got something for everybody.
Now every once in a while I do a Q
and a format where people will vote on
questions, submit an upvote questions just
like you have in the past week or two,
so several thousand people voted on
questions and I have the top 10 to 15 and
I'm going to tackle as many as
I can in the next short stint,
the short period that we have together
before I have to run to dinner.
So let me start at the beginning,
but before we jump into the questions,
I want to recommend that you
check out my movie picks.
I watch a lot of movies and I uncover
some pretty fun ones because I dig very
deep and I searched far and wide
for lots of weird esoteric stuff.
If you go to four hour work,
week.com all spelled out, Fou, r,
h our etc. Four hour work
week.com forward slash Vimeo,
Vimeo as a sponsor and I have
been a member for many years now.
Uh, if you go to four hour
workweek.com forward slash Vimeo,
you can find some of the movies
that have been amazing for me,
inspiring game changing or in some cases
life changing. There are some really,
really impressive movies. And before
I've spoken about, for instance,
a science fiction short
called world of tomorrow,
which was the winner of the grand jury
prize at Sundance for short films and is
just a really thought provoking
intense 16 minutes or so.
I've mentioned waking up with Sam Harris,
which is actually a lecture
and effectively a class,
which is the perfect tool if you want
to explore mindfulness and meditation.
And for those of you who have
listened to a lot of these podcasts,
you know that perhaps 80%
of the top performers all
have some type of meditative
practice and can differ.
Uh, whether that is,
say a Dj or a founder of the glitch
mob all the way to Swartz and anger,
they all have some type of mindfulness
practice. Then you have the,
the act of killing,
which is probably the most brutal
innovative documentary I've ever seen. Uh,
and many more. So they, they have, uh,
just about anything you can imagine from
documentaries on the revival of manual
work through motorcycles, which is
super cool. You can check that out.
He breakdancing documentary.
And the one that I want to highlight
today is a very short film called the lady
in number six. And The lady and
number six is an Oscar winner.
It is a short about Alice,
you know,
Alice is 109 years old and the world's
oldest pianist and Holocaust survivor.
And this short film is
really mind expanding for me.
Uh, was mine expanding for
me in a number of respects.
It just shows the importance of mental
framing and also how your perspective can
lead to happiness or resentment
at any given point in time.
And there are a number of people in the
film who appear besides Alice and you
can look at the, their demeanors and the
contrast and perspectives. It's very,
very interesting. But 109 years old,
very, very sharp, still moving around,
playing the piano every day.
I've found it a really enlightening and,
uh, engrossing watch. And it's a,
it's only give 20 to 30 minutes long.
So the, the, uh, name again
is the lady and number six,
you can go four hour work week.com forward
slash Vimeo and I will be continuing
to add movies to this page. Uh,
the are not affiliate links,
but I do have a discount for you guys for
any of the films that you might watch,
so you can check that out.
Um,
but the subtitle is listened to the
secrets for a long and happy life.
So the lady number six, check it
out. It's short. Well worth the time.
Go to four hour work week.com. Forward
slash, Vimeo. All right, now moving on.
Let's get to the very first
question. Just jump into it. And a,
I think I'll spend a good amount of
time on this question and I've omitted a
handful of those that were voted up at
cause I thought the wording was weird or
confusing. Um, so the first one I'm going
to tackle is this question from Mike.
In Santa Cruz.
They say blogging 1.0 is dead.
If you had to build an audience from
scratch today, how would you start? Well,
this is a tricky question because, uh, uh,
you may be tackling the wrong problem.
And let me explain how I
think about this and just to,
to put things in perspective.
So I have a number of platforms.
I obviously have the blog, which
gets somewhere between, I dunno, uh,
one and 2 million unique
visitors per month. Uh,
then I have my Twitter and social
Twitter alone gets, I don't know,
1.3 million or so in terms of
followers and then the podcast,
which just hundreds of thousands
per episode and so on and so forth.
So I've tried it all right. I've played
around with any platform you can imagine.
And I live in silicon valley in
invest in tech. Here's my perspective.
So I'll answer your question
somewhat directly in literally first,
there is always a market for high quality
and there's always a market for long
form. Okay? I'm going to recommend a
couple of resources right off the bat. Uh,
there's always a market for high quality.
Uh, there's a book called small giants.
I would recommend that you check out.
Uh,
and this is to say if you
offer the best of anything, uh,
you can charge a premium
and your customers were 10
will tend to be very high
margin,
low headache customers.
So you could say produce the best cigar
in the world or even the top 10% and
charge hundreds or thousands
of dollars per cigar.
You could do the same thing with leather
pants and sell them to people like
Sheryl Crow and only make a couple of
hundred or even fewer per year and make
hundreds of thousands or
millions of dollars per year.
That's actually an
example from small giants.
This is related to long form and
that's how I interpret blogging.
One Point Oh is writing blog posts and
then having comments on those posts.
There's always a market for long form
and people lament the death of long form
the death of this, the death
of that. Oh my God. You know,
TV is going to be the death of radio and
podcasts are going to be the death of
this and this is going
to be the death of that.
And it makes for very
sensational headlines. But, uh,
I think it's usually mostly hot air.
So long form.
Here's the advantage of long form content.
And I've always specialized, I think in
long form content, you look at my books,
they're not short.
They're not intended for people who claim
to have short attention spans and many
of my blog posts or 15 pages long,
2030 pages long if you print them out.
Uh,
and the reason I approach it this way is
because if you're building an audience,
and I'll come back to that
aspect of your question, the,
the most labor efficient way to build an
audience over time is to have evergreen
content. So I write long pieces that
will be more valuable from an Seo,
a real estate standpoint,
two years from the date I write it
compared to the week it launches,
if that makes sense. So were you to
look at my back catalog and the stats?
I'm on wordpress VIP. If you were to
look at my stats or Google analytics,
you would see that my most
popular posts that get hunt get,
get each hundreds of thousands of visits
per month were written several years
ago. And that's very much by design.
I'm not upset by that because I,
I fully expect that some of the articles
I write this year, for instance,
my post on a practical
thoughts on suicide,
which is a very intense post,
uh,
I expect that will continue to gather
steam and be spread around and shared.
And a year from now it will be
right in the top 10 rankings,
which is very important to me.
So the question you asked though,
it has a very, uh, is,
is a multilayered question and there
are a lot of assumptions built into it.
So if you had to build an audience
from scratch today, let's examine that.
Why do you have to build an audience at
all now the belief right now is you have
to be on social. You have to be putting
out content. I think that's bullshit.
You don't have to at all. Amazon
didn't start with building an audience.
Uber didn't start with
building an audience.
If your goal is to create a profitable
or massively scaled business,
that may not be the right thing to
focus on. Uh, that's, that's part one.
Part two is I encourage you to always ask
yourself why three times when you feel
like you have to do something. So you have
to build an audience, ask three times,
and this is something I think
I adopted from Cardo, similar,
which is spelled with an Ra,
is a Brazilian entrepreneur
asking why three times?
So why do you have to build an
audience? Well, and you might say,
because I have to have people to
sell to when I launched my product.
Okay, well why do you have
to launch your product? Well,
because I want to build a business
that allows me to the freedom.
Let's just say to travel the world and
have enough income to do a, B, and c.
All right,
let's take travel the world.
It may turn out once you ask why three
times that volunteering at a local
embassy for your target country like
Sweden or someplace else is the shortest
path to getting to your objective,
not building an audience.
So don't mistake the intermediate
signposts or not even signposts.
The intermediate steps that you've been
told repeatedly are important as the
goal itself. Uh, and this,
this comes back to a lot of the discussion
in the four hour work week about
multiple currencies and the fact that
that income is only one currency of time.
You have mobility and that the value of
that money is determined by the number
of W's you control in your life. You
know, where you live, what you do,
who you spend your time with and so on.
And the reality that
income is a barter system.
You are taking this paper or digital,
uh,
symbolism basically these
units and trading them for
experiences or possessions.
So there may be more direct
ways like volunteering,
like taking a specific job,
uh, any number of things, uh,
that could get you to your goal faster
than building an audience because
building an audience, quite frankly,
it's a pain in the ass. It is a,
it is not an easy thing and
it requires a very concerted,
conscious and well planned effort.
Okay.
Couple of other recommendations,
if you still decide to that building an
audience is the right step or the right
place to focus.
A couple of things.
I would suggest read the article
1000 true fans by Kevin Kelly.
Uh, this is an important concept to grasp
because you do not want to target the
mass,
the masses.
Your objective should not be to
build the largest audience possible.
It's too vague. It would be too expensive
in terms of cost per acquisition.
Even if that cost is measured in the
man hours that you put into creating
content. The least crowded
channel is where he should focus.
That's another reason why
I prefer long form content.
The least crowded channel
is still long form content,
whether that is print or audio.
And that is why I am able to
compete effectively. For instance,
in the podcast realm,
even though my podcasts are very
minimally produced, I don't have a team.
It's me and one freelance engineer
and my assistant. That's it. Uh,
but I can compete against podcasts
that have many, many teams, many,
many people in groups of people
focused on producing a narrative. Uh,
partially because I, I go very
in depth with guests. Um, this,
this episode of course being
a, an exception, I mean
anomaly few other points.
If you're trying to build an audience,
the first place to start,
and this is gonna sound funny,
is to look at your credit card statement.
All right?
Look at your monthly credit card
statements and identify where you are.
Price incentives and price insensitive.
Okay?
So you could have a specific
highlighter for that.
Let's just say they're printed out.
Use An orange highlighter, red,
whatever for things that you are price
insensitive about where you could spend
three or four times as much and not care.
You should also break things into groups.
Where do you spend $100 a year? Okay.
So obviously you're
going to have to divide,
some things are multiplying them by 12,
but what do you spend $100 a year on?
What do you spend $250 a year on?
What do you spend $500 a year on and
what do you spend $1,000 a year on a?
And if you're in a, uh, a
very high income bracket,
then you can multiply those out
obviously. Okay. That's step one.
And the price insensitive
aspect is very important.
If you want minimal headache from
the customers that you choose.
Next you're going to identify the
subcultures that you belong to.
What are the subcultures you belong to?
Are you a crossfitter?
Are you involved with orienteering?
Are you into role playing
games or world of Warcraft?
Do you like particular types of movie?
Are you into Japan animation,
whatever it is,
identify three to five sub cultures that
you belong to that you understand very
well.
And then for each of those sub cultures,
you're going to identify the five
sites that those people go to.
If you had to guess where someone
in that subculture would go.
The five sites that they go to regularly,
three to five,
the three to five Twitter accounts,
they're most likely to follow the
three to five Instagram accounts.
They're most likely to follow the three
to five Facebook pages they're most
likely to like or be fans of the three
to five podcasts that they're likely to
listen to.
And let's just stop it there and you
don't have to do all of them but SPEC that
out. And what are you doing
by following this process?
What you're doing is defining yourself,
your psychographics, your
demographics, and uh,
the,
my,
my first recommendation is always going
to be go after markets that you belong
to. So when I launched the four hour
workweek, my objective was initially,
and the target is not
the potential market.
This is really important to understand.
The target market is
not your total market.
The target market is the tip of the spear.
That is what you use at the front lines
to win the battle that then allows you
to win the war,
but you win the war when your target
demographic then expands to include a lot
of other people. In practical
terms, what does this mean?
When I launched the four hour work week,
my objective was very measurable
and what gets measured gets managed.
As Peter Drucker says,
I was going after 20,000 sales of
the four hour work week per week two,
I think it was 20 to 35 year old tech
savvy males in New York and San Francisco
have predominantly Chicago also.
Um,
and this is because I did the homework.
Looking at Nielsen Bookscan,
I had a good idea of what would be
necessary to hit the New York Times
bestseller list.
I knew what type of distribution I needed,
hence the importance of
Chicago and having, uh,
not only sales,
limited to the coasts and I also knew
that I belonged to this 25 to a 40 year
old, is that what I said? 25 to 40 year
old tax haven male demographic. Therefore,
I knew how to appear ubiquitous to
these people in a cost effective way.
So follow me. I knew that if I
were able to get on at the time,
say Gizmodo tech crunch a Gawker
perhaps and a handful of other sites,
then uh, now Twitter was nascent in
this day and Instagram didn't exist.
But if I was able to appear at say,
two or three or four conferences
that these people attended,
I could appear as though I'm
spending millions of dollars, uh,
or being recruited by all these companies
in publications around the world when
in fact,
I only was targeting a handful in a
very concerted and a surgical way.
Okay. You're not trying to build
the largest audience possible.
You're trying to find your 1000 true fans.
So to bring it home,
just review all this stuff.
You're trying to find your 1000 true fans
who belong to subcultures and markets
you belong to so that you can then design
a product or service that they will be
pricing sensitive to.
And in doing all of that,
finding a handful of outlets or pages
or accounts that you can target.
So that you can very cost effectively
appear ubiquitous in a surround sound way
when you launch something
important to you. And that is it.
By focusing on the least crowded channel,
you can win at surprisingly low costs and
with very elegant surgical approaches.
And uh, that is a long answer
to question number one.
So I'm going to go get a glass of water,
but hopefully you guys find
that useful and I will be back.
Okay, I'm back. You gorgeous, filthy
animals and I'm going to do a speed round,
uh, at least to the extent that I can do
a speed round in jam through a bunch of
these questions here.
The next question is from Mike
M in Hoboken as well as Holly.
Holly asked a very similar question.
If you're the average of the five people
you surround yourself with or associate
with most, who are those five people
for you? This varies very widely.
It depends a lot on what
my goals are and I'm,
I'm not purely pragmatic
about my friends either.
These need to be people
I enjoy hanging out with.
So it's not just for furthering the goal
of averaging out to a higher standard.
But, uh, the first few names that come
to mind, uh, currently our Kevin Rose,
Josh Waitzkin. So Kevin Rose,
entrepreneur, serial founder
has been on the podcast,
Josh Waitzkin,
known as a chess prodigy.
The inspiration for searching for Bobby
Fischer has also been on this podcast,
a Garrett camp who a co founder of
Uber Found a cofounder of stumble upon,
et Cetera.
I do a lot of work with him,
but he is not on the podcast
and probably won't be, um,
because he doesn't do as much PR as
people like me. Jeffrey Zurawski.
So Jay z is his nickname.
Jeffrey's Zurawski was a chef featured
in the four hour chef. He was very,
very helpful. We did a lot of
ridiculous things in that book,
including the New York City food
marathon where we had something like 26.2
dishes in 24 hours over God knows
how many different locations and uh,
suppose right now, 65 year
old or older, 60 year plus,
let's just say 60 or plus very fit dudes.
So older guys who are in incredible
shape who I have trouble keeping up with,
I'm really making a study of their
longevity and just general life practices
that lead to that type of existence.
And then lastly, I'd say the,
the the Rick Ruben's of the world to
Rick Rubin, legendary music producer. Uh,
he was recently on the
podcast, very zen, very calm,
very unflappable. And I wouldn't say any
of those things come naturally to me.
So that is the short answer to
that question. Next question.
This is from Barry in Glasgow.
Based on the self experiments
you conducted in your books,
are there any habits you continue
to implement on a daily basis?
And I would expand the
experiments in the books too.
Also the blog and elsewhere
and there are plenty,
there are tons that I continue to follow,
uh,
whether that's using cold baths as well
as heat exposure to facilitate sleep.
Uh, there was, uh, uh,
a piece that was put on the blog with
doctor Rhonda Patrick about using Saunas
and heat for growth hormone increase.
You can check that out.
Journaling in the morning.
I use the five minute journal,
which was inspired by the
four hour workweek. In fact,
the people who created read the book and
then created the five minute journal.
So that's a nice virtuous cycle.
But I use the five minute journal
typically in the mornings,
although I tried to do it at night
as well as a way to focus my day.
The no complaint experiment that I
wrote about on the blog sometime ago.
Go trying to go 21 days
without complaining.
And the parameters for that is something
that I'm experimenting with right now
and that involves wearing a bracelet
that can be swapped from rooster wrist.
The training program in
effortless superhuman in the
four hour body is something
that I follow, uh, generally
on and off depending on,
on what my goals are.
But if strength is the goal and there's
almost always a component of that,
the sex chapters, those,
those get good use. Uh,
hopefully more and more use.
But those are in the four hour body,
the four hour work week I would say.
And certainly slow carb.
The silica have died. I've been following
for something like 10 years now,
although I'm in a in a ketogenic
experimentation phase at the moment.
Then you have the four hour work week
and I use stuff from all of these books.
So many of the recipes and the four
hour chef, sexy times steak and so on.
I use all the time,
four hour workweek,
80 20 principle and analysis automation,
autoresponders,
all of that stuff is
implemented on a daily basis.
Just had a phone call with one
of my right hands yesterday.
Going through and rank ordering
a bunch of things and we'll,
we'll get to some of that in a later
question and in fact we'll get to in the
next question,
which is from Arturo in Mexico.
What is the most important question
you ask yourself every day?
Closely related to the last question and
I think that question has to be which
of these,
and these are the items on my to do list.
So if you have a to do
list in front of you,
which of these if done make
the rest easier or irrelevant.
This is something that I've
asked for many, many years,
but we're really looking for,
and I don't think I'm the
only person to call it this,
but looking for the lead
domino. Uh, so the, the, the,
the domino at the front
that once tipped over,
we'll help make all the others happen
automatically make them all much easier to
do or make them irrelevant.
So if you have multiple say revenue
goals and they're one that could have a
disproportionate Roi for the
number of hours invested,
then that may make three or four other
revenue options irrelevant if that's
going to potentially comprise 80% of
what you would make from that entire two
list, for instance. So which of these if
done makes the rest easier or irrelevant?
Another question I ask a lot is, which
of these makes me the most uncomfortable?
And it's hard to define
important. I know that this, this,
it can get very complex very quickly
trying to define what is most important.
And, uh, I will spit spend time
talking about that term right now,
but instead of trying
to define certain terms,
you can just ignore
them or leave them out.
And that solves a lot of problems.
And we talked about sort of the, the,
the trouble with the word success in
the four hour workweek for instance. Uh,
but you can ask which of these makes me
the most uncomfortable and that from 80
20 analysis if done is
going to reduce anxiety, uh,
and improve quality of life,
the greatest potentially,
and that often correlates to what
you would consider important.
So if you don't know what
the most important thing is
to do on your do to list,
find the one,
find the item that makes you the most
uncomfortable and that's probably it. Uh,
next question.
If you could make one thing mandatory in
the nationwide high school curriculum,
what would it be? This is, uh, from, uh,
also from Mike and Santa Cruz who's
pretty good voting on his questions. Uh,
so this is a potentially long conversation
about the first one may be some
unexpected and that is mandatory sports
to keep kids occupied and focused and
improving themselves from three to 6:00
PM. That's known as the danger zone,
a for afterschool programs. But when
kids have idle hands from three to six,
often before their
parents get off of work,
that's when a lot of kids go off the
rails. So I think mandatory sports,
which I had in high school starting in
sophomore year, I just thought it was,
it was very powerful as a
tool. All right, next question.
This is from Jerry a and Philadelphia.
Bruce Lee said the quote,
the successful warrior is the average
man with laser like focus and quote.
What methods do you practice to maintain,
focus and follow through to achieve your
goals rather than getting sidetracked,
distracted or discouraged?
Uh,
first point that I'll make in answer
to that is that I do get sidetracked,
distracted and discouraged. Uh,
there's a post I wrote called,
I think it's productivity hacks for the
neurotic, manic depressive and crazy.
And then in parentheses, like
me. So if you just search, uh,
productivity hacks for the neurotic,
uh,
and then my name will pop right up just
to give you an accurate picture of what
my days and weeks look like.
So number one,
don't expect that you're going
to eliminate that stuff 100%.
That's setting yourself up for
failure or feeling like a failure.
You're going to get sidetracked,
distracted and discouraged.
The question is what can you do to
minimize that or more importantly,
because the goal isn't minimizing,
getting sidetracked,
the goal is getting really big things
done or getting things done that have
outsized returns and results,
right?
So there are a couple of things
that I find very helpful.
Number one is a chrome
extension called momentum.
This will prevent you from getting lost
on the Internet display is a beautiful
photo with a quote and then your
most important task for the day.
And we already talked about important,
so I won't Belabor it,
but the momentum extension for chrome,
check it out.
The next is thinking of my day is
split into maker period and manage your
period. And there's a great
essay by Paul Graham called,
I think it's just the maker's schedule
versus the manager's schedule,
something like that.
Uh,
up until about lunchtime
or early afternoon,
I tried to produce content,
uh,
and focus on writing or recording
audio answered questions like this for
instance. And then after lunch, uh,
where my brain is typically dialed down
in terms of Rpms after eating. Anyway,
I try to focus on the administrative
stuff, the managing the conference calls,
the making the trains run on time stuff.
And then the five minute journal I
already mentioned that helps me to keep
somewhat focused and the follow through
is related to that since you do a recap
and a postmortem on your day every
evening for a few minutes. Next question,
scooter from silly valley.
I don't know if that is a real place,
but I kinda like the name
silly valley question.
With all the misleading
information on health out there,
what are the best or most reliable
resources? This is very tough question.
What I would say is as Richard Fiman
would say, a physicist and a hero of mine,
uh, the most important thing is not to
trick yourself and you are the most,
you are the easiest person or not to
fool yourself and you are the easiest
person to fool. Something
along those lines. Uh,
there's a book called bad
science that you should read.
A bad science is written by an MD named
Ben Goldacre and it teaches you how to
parse good science from bad science,
uh,
and to learn how to evaluate
headlines in the news that are usually
sensationalist or written by people who
don't understand how to read studies
properly and perhaps a bit of both.
Uh,
and I did take some excerpts from that
and created a appendix or I should say
bonus chapter in the four hour body
that goes through a lot of this.
So you can check that out too
if you have a copy of the book,
the condensed a lot of that at
the back of the four hour body.
But you need to educate yourself so
that you can separate fact from fiction,
good science from bad science, good
studies from bad studies, et cetera.
And it doesn't take that long.
You can in an afternoon, uh,
for most people double your ability to
be intelligent about evaluating all of
the stuff that gets thrown at you.
Mostly noise, very rare signal. Um,
but, uh, that is that.
All right. Let's see, uh,
the next question I'm gonna answer is,
what are your top 10 natural
supplements that you found most helpful?
And I want to answer this question because
I am of the mind now that you want to
minimize supplementation because
supplements should be supplements.
Unless you have a clear deficiency
that you cannot fix through diet, uh,
you should attempt to fix it through diet,
optimize through diet.
And there are a couple of easy
ways to do that. I like to, uh,
so there are foods that I can
see them regularly. For instance,
I mean coconut oil, Brazil
nuts, et cetera. Uh,
I try to consume a diet that
includes a spectrum of colors.
So I will often order
food or get for instance,
materials from a salad bar based on
getting as wide a spectrum of different
colors as possible.
I think that allows you and helps you to
cover a lot of bases. And then the last,
uh, there's a supplement I
use. I've used it for years,
talked about it in the four
hour body athletic Greens,
which is kind of my insurance policy
to cover things that I hit. Um,
but there are,
I would never take 10 supplements.
And natural is really a,
uh,
a dicey distinction or description
because natural does not mean good,
does not mean safe. A hemlock
is natural, it'll kill you. Uh,
natural and synthetic are not
always great distinctions,
but whole food supplements, supplements
derived from whole food, uh,
I think are generally,
uh, all things equal,
which they never are
better than synthetic.
But also if you're doing something like
a recombinant human growth hormone,
right,
you want human growth hormone that's
been synthesized and not pulled out of
cadavers, they're more dangerous
with the latter than the former.
So that is a long way
of saying I don't use,
I try not to use any supplements all
the time because you develop tolerance.
Is there feedback mechanisms
that can screw up your own, um,
endogenous or sort of a production in
your own body by over supplementation?
So I'm trying to go whole foods whenever
possible athletic Greens when I feel
like I'm probably not covering
my bases are traveling on.
Next question from chase in Kentucky.
Uh,
and his question is what are the things
you've done to become a better writer?
Uh, I still don't, I'm not
satisfied with myself as a writer.
I think I'm a better
teacher than I am a writer.
So that has a lot to do with how I format
the sequencing of things in my books
and simplification of things.
But a couple of things.
Number one is read outside of your genre.
So even if you're a nonfiction writer,
read good fiction, don't
become a bigot. A genre wise.
Couple of books I found very helpful on
writing with Stephen King's simple and
direct, uh, on writing well by,
I can never pronounce his last name.
I think it's William Zinsser winner on
the psychological game of writing and
just actually getting past your own
head, uh, and insecurities to right.
I think that bird by bird is one
of the best books out there. Uh,
if you can't find a professor
or someone who has a, a,
a writer per se,
to proof or review your writing,
uh,
then find a lawyer,
find a lawyer to look at your stuff,
even if they're not a good writer, so to
speak, or don't consider themselves such,
they're very good at removing
extraneous words or nebulous words. Uh,
so that, that is a tip. And then,
uh, get into the practice of writing.
Uh,
so I use morning pages.
You can use any number of different types
of journals if you just search what my
morning journal looks
like and then my name,
what my morning journal
looks like in my name.
You'll see examples of how
I do that. And the, uh,
the specific journal that I use just
to get into the habit of writing for
yourself. They're not
intended for publication. Uh,
and then when I am having my
material proof read by people,
my general rule is if one person
loves something, it stays in.
So I only need a vote of
one to keep something.
But if one person hates something
that's not enough to get rid of it.
So I need a consensus to remove something.
Uh, but I only need one person to love
something for me to keep it in or have to
strongly, strongly consider keeping
it in. Uh, and that is that for now.
I'm sure there are other things,
but those are the ones that come to mind.
Next question. This is at proposal idea.
Alright. From Kentucky, we all have
times when he, when we need a brain dump.
What are your guilty pleasures for those
times when your brain needs a rest?
So I think of brain dump is just
getting a lot out of your head in a
brainstorming session without editing.
But let's assume I'm
answering the second part,
which is when my brain needs a rest,
what do I do? Uh, I like hand drumming.
I have a gem bays, which is Dj e. M. B. E.
I have a hand pan, which is kind of
like a steel drum turned inside out. Uh,
I also watched serial
television. Um, but it's,
it's not appointment viewing,
I'm downloading say true
detective or something like that.
And then watching each
episode, the jinx. Also,
it's just coincidence that both
those are very, very dark. Uh,
the something a little lighter.
I read fiction and I actually really
like reading kids' books or young adult
books because I think the books that are
really well written and stand the test
of time in the young
adult category or just,
well written books don't have a lot
of extraneous bullshit or you know,
$10 words when a 10
cent word will suffice.
And I think the just very well written
a wrinkle in time is one that was gifted
to me,
uh,
not too long ago and recently read
that and just loved it. It was a,
it was a really fun read
and a very relaxing to read
before bed to turn off the
problem solving apparatus in my own mind.
Uh,
so that is my answer for the brain dump.
Taking a rest. Those are a few
things that I find very helpful. Uh,
and then there are a
bunch of questions here.
I'm just going to answer one more and
then get going and let you guys get back
to your day.
So bleak you and you can charge
forth and conquer worlds.
Uh, last question from Jamie.
This is a oh boy could Asha Sta,
UK, Gloucester, I don't
know how to pronounce it. G.
L. O. U. C. E. S. T. E. R.
It's like worst to tire sauce,
Worcester sauce.
I can't ever pronounce those damn words.
In any case,
what would you go back and
tell your younger self?
I've thought about this a lot in my answer
for a long time was, you know, nothing,
I wouldn't change anything because these,
these questions are related.
What would you change if you
could go back to age 20 or 25,
what would you do differently?
The very close related,
the only thing that I've
been able to think of,
and this is only very recently that I
realized this is start meditating. Uh,
I think that I would recommend to
myself that I start meditating earlier.
I've talked about this
quite a lot. Um, in a,
in 80 plus percent of the
people I interview for the
podcast are all world class
performers, best of the best, have some
type of meditative practice. And um,
there are some very good books related to
that. Uh, wherever you go. There you are.
I think it is Jon Kabat Zinn.
Uh,
there's also a book called
radical acceptance by Tara
Brock that I like a lot.
Vrac h that's, that covers
more than just meditation. Um,
and then, uh, last but not least, I,
well I should say I practice
transcendental meditation
and Vipassana Meditation,
but there are many different
types of trends. Tm,
transcendental meditation is just tm.org.
You can find info there.
There's things I dislike about it.
I think it should be much less
expensive to get training,
but that's what I needed. Iee, someone
to hold me accountable to get into it.
Other things,
apps like headspace and called very,
very good for getting started and,
uh,
do less than you think
you can do for meditation.
This is key for a lot
of behavioral change,
but if you think you can sit for
10 minutes, do it for five, uh,
give yourself a margin for
error and for frustration.
So if you think you can do
15 minutes, great, do 10, uh,
but do what will allow you
to win in the beginning.
The habit is more important than hitting
home runs every day in the beginning.
Uh,
and then last I will
say check out waking up.
Uh, this is the, the lecture
by Sam Harris who is, is,
is just an incredible human being.
A phd in neuroscience friend of mine.
He's also on the podcast. And, uh,
waking up is an outstanding
introduction and, uh, and uh,
collection of instruction really
related to meditation. Uh,
so sort of a guide to spirituality
without religion as his subtitle. But, uh,
waking up is a great video.
You can check it out,
as I mentioned at the very beginning,
at four hour workweek.com,
forward slash Vimeo, all spelled out four
hour workweek.com, forward slash, Vimeo.
And in terms of that
brain dump and relaxing,
you can also find other things that I've
watched before bed or on the weekends
to chill out like the greasy hands,
preachers. Uh, they're all there.
Shake the dust valley uprising,
a world of tomorrow, maiden trip,
etc. Act of killing, not so relaxing,
but a fantastic documentary. Nonetheless,
the most brutal thing probably
you will ever watch in your life.
So those are my picks.
I'll be adding to this over time.
So check that out@fourhourworkweek.com
forward slash and Vimeo. And uh,
for those of you who are listening,
if you have a company or product or
brand and you're interested in sponsoring
this podcast,
then I would like to hear from you
because I'm gonna be doing a lot of really
fun stuff coming up soon.
Just go to four hour workweek,
all spelled out for our work week.com
forward slash sponsor. Uh, and uh,
there's a short form,
fill it out and uh,
I or my team will chicken
out soon. So, uh, please let
me know. Four hour workweek,
dotcom forward slash. Sponsor. That
is, it. Have a wonderful day, evening,
week,
month life until I speak to you next time.
Thanks for listening and
[inaudible] keep it real.